um so today we'll be finishing up some
of the things that we didn't have time
to cover last time on optimization based
on learning and then we'll also be
covering nonparametric approaches to
future learning before we get started
with the technical content a few
reminders so homework one is due on
Wednesday and homework two is coming out
this Wednesday homework two will include
both you'll both implement Mammal as we
just as we covered last week and you'll
also be implementing prototypical
networks which is a nonparametric
approach to future learning which we'll
cover today posted a form for you to
fill out on the poster preferences this
is the preferences for the date of the
poster session please fill this out I
think that last time we checked only
like five people had filled it out we're
trying to schedule a venue for the
poster session now and the we have a
better venue that's booked for Tuesday
the third but we want to make sure that
people are available that day because
it's not during the normal course
session time so please fill out that
form we also posted details on the
course project and instructions
including instructions for the proposal
the milestone and the final project and
poster session so please take a look at
that we also posted some suggestions
that were from the broader AI community
on Piazza and the proposal which is the
first part of the project is due on
Monday October 28th but we encourage you
to get started early and to find teeth
or figure out what you want to do before
that alone or to find a group to work
with okay so the plan for today first
we'll cover optimization based medal
earning basically recap what we covered
last week very briefly and then discuss
some more advanced topics and then we'll
cover a nonparametric few shot learning
this will probably be the bulk of the
lecture and this will include things
like siamese networks matching networks
and prototypical networks as well as
some other hybrid approaches and then
lastly we'll be covering properties of
metal learning algorithms and basically
how we can think about comparing the
classes of approaches that we've seen so
far and the types of things that we
might want when developing a new metal
learning algorithms okay so that's kind
of a summary of what we'll go over today
so first let's recap from last time so
we talked about how fine to
is a very effective way for leveraging
information from previous data sets by
pre-training the parameters on those
data sets and then fine-tuning by
running gradient descent or or your
favorite optimizer to reuse those
features that were learned for learning
on your new data set and then we talked
about well can we think about how we
might go about the pre trading process
in a principled way especially if we
want to be able to fine tune with very
small amounts of data at test time and
then we talked about one way to do that
so one way to do that is basically by
trying to embed this fine-tuning
procedure into the meta learning process
by taking this fine-tuning procedure
evaluating how well the resulting
fine-tune parameters do well on held-out
data and then simply optimizing this
objective with respect to a set of
pre-trained parameters across a wide
range of tasks okay so kind of this was
the model agnostic meta learning
algorithm that we discussed and this
optimizes for an effective
initialization for fine tuning all right
we also discussed how the well is
performs on extrapolated tasks and we
found that it works quite well in
comparison to the black box allocation
approaches and we also looked at the
expressive power and show that the
expressive power of these models of
these algorithms is quite substantial if
you have a deep enough they're all
networked and it kind of requires a bit
more a bit more excessive power the
architecture in comparison to block box
approaches ok so now I'd like to talk a
bit about some other properties of these
kinds of algorithms and different ways
that we could extend the algorithm to
address various challenges so first one
one thing that we talked about actually
towards the beginning is how you can
view meta parameters theta as serving as
a prior for task specific adaptation
where it's kind of this prior is
encapsulating the is encapsulating the
knowledge and your Mediterranean data
set so can we make this more formal so
it turns out we can actually make a bit
of a deeper connection than just saying
that it's going to form it's kind of
kind of formats loose prior
initialization for fine-tuning and
particularly to see this let's look at
the following graphical model so theta
is representing our meta parameters and
Phi is denoting the top specific
parameters the parameters for each task
and then the shaded circle is
representing the data points that we
have for each task and it's traded
because we could observe those during
the meditating process know if you think
about how how you might go about doing
inference in this graphical model we
assume that we have this data so we want
to maximize the likelihood of our data
set given our meta parameters this is
essentially how you would go about doing
inference in this graphical model with
respect to the metal learned parameters
okay
and you can also write this out as kind
of a sum of log likelihoods as well and
then from there we can introduce this
second very introduced our top specific
parameters phi i these are going to be
integrated out because we're trying to
optimize over our meta parameters data
and so hence we're just expanding this
expression for p date probability of the
data given the meta parameters into
probability of the data given the top
specific parameters and the probability
of the top specific parameter is given
theta where that second term is
representing the prior that theta is
enforcing or imposing on our top
specific parameters and this corresponds
to empirical Bayes approaches to for
like operating this higher cool Bayesian
model so now from here this this
integral over all possible top specific
parameters is compiled particularly when
we have large numbers of parameters
right so you don't really have a good
way to think about performing this
optimization in any exact way and so
what we can do is we can say well let's
fairly crudely approximate this integral
with a point estimate for Phi I which is
going to represent the maximum a
posteriori estimate of those parameters
this is a of course a crude
approximation but it is something that
well at least the map estimate is a
better choice for these parameters than
other choice
because it has the maximal probability
of course now the question comes in well
okay if we're gonna make this
approximation to try to to represent our
objective at the top how do we compute
the map estimate well it turns out that
under specific conditions gradient
descent with early stopping corresponds
to map inference with under Gaussian
prior with mean at the initial
parameters and a variance that is
determined by the number of gradient
steps and the step size and this is
exact in a linear case and approximate
in the nonlinear case and so what this
means is that if we're doing kind of
getting the map estimate by running
gradient descent with early stopping
that corresponds to the inner loop of
the mammal objective and you can then
loosely view mammals approximating
hierarchical Bayesian inference in this
graphical model of course this involves
several approximations one approximation
that is using the map estimate and
another approximation which is thinking
about gradient descent with early
stopping as map inference in the
nonlinear case with neural networks but
I think that this kind of interpretation
is helpful for getting some intuition
for what these kinds of approaches are
doing yeah for early stopping so in the
case of mammal we just pick a certain
number of gradient steps we pick one
gradient stop or five gradient steps and
that particular the variance of this
Gaussian prior is determined by the
number of gradient steps that you use
and the step size that you use for those
created stops so I guess unlike typical
neural network training we're just kind
of picking picking the number of
gradient steps rather than choosing a
stopping criterion based off a
validation error for example I'm so you
can essentially view like the
initialization of these parameters as
serving as an actual explicit prior in a
Bayesian model okay
so you can do this form of
initialization with a few gradient steps
is one form of implicit prior on the on
the top specific parameters and there
are other ways to think about priors
that we could impose on
the optimization process so for example
one thing we could do is instead of
having this implicit prior that's
imposed by only doing a few small number
of gradient steps we could have a
explicit Gaussian prior where we are
actually regularizing the inner
optimization to be close to our meta
parameters theta and so this would
correspond to an explicit Gaussian prior
with me and theta and a variance that is
a function of lambda so this is
basically the form of like the log
likelihood of a Gaussian another form of
prior that we could do is we can be even
more split more explicit and actually
trying to represent do basically a form
of Bayesian linear regression on top of
learn features and represent the mean
and variance of that represent the mean
and variance of that Bayesian linear
regression as meta parameters themselves
so these are kind of two forms of a
gradient based meta learning algorithms
that have tried to place explicit priors
on it another class of methods have
looked at just having the prior be
imposed based off of the feature space
and what you're learning on so kind of
similar to this last approach where
they're doing Bayesian linear regression
on the last layer there are also a
number of approaches that have done an
optimization on top of learn features
such as performing Ridge regression or
logistic regression on top of learn
features in the inner loop as well as a
support vector machine on those learn
features so essentially these different
these corresponds to different inner
loops of the meta optimization algorithm
and then the meta training process
involves differentiating through these
inner loops by either treating them as a
closed form optimization as a convex
optimization problem that you can
differentiate through or other
optimizations okay in this last approach
I this may be out of date now but as of
a few months ago it was the state of the
art on future cost image classification
benchmarks although to do that they
introduced a number of bells and
whistles in order to get it to kind of
reach that it wasn't just the the
approach itself Oh in many ways those
those bells and whistles are often
important for getting getting stadia our
performance on benchmarks okay cool so
now let's go over a few of the
challenges that come up with these types
of approaches so one challenge is that
we we just talked about how Mammal you
may need much deeper networks in order
to be able to effectively get an
expressive gradient update that can
represent a number of different update
rules to your parameters and so how do
we think about choosing the architecture
for that is effective for mammal-like
algorithms and so what idea for this is
there's a paper that looked at can we do
a neural architecture search on the
mammal architecture such that meta
learning works well they've called this
Auto meta in the sense that you're doing
both auto ml and meta learning and one
of the things that was interesting about
this paper is that they found that
highly non-standard architectures were
actually effective for mammal in
contrast to their effectiveness for for
kind of standard supervised learning
problems so for example they found that
deep and narrow architectures tend to
work well and these were kind of
different from the architectures that
work well on steroids supervised
learning and so for example if you take
mini imagenet with the basic
architecture that reaches around 63
percent performance mammal with this
kind of optimized architecture I saw at
11 percent absolute improvement in
performance which is pretty substantial
yeah
Oh like specifically what the changes
were it involved it was a fairly complex
architecture as met what many of these
architecture search things give you it
was much deeper maybe like two or three
orders of magnitude deeper and and from
what I remember it was also narrower
they also had some operations that were
a bit non-standard in neural networks
something like 1x1 convolutions or
something like that but it's been a
while since I I've read the paper ok so
another challenge that comes up is that
you have this by level optimization
procedure that we need to perform in
order before
learning and this can exhibit some
instabilities particularly if you don't
have as much expressive power that you'd
like in your current architecture and
there been a few different ideas for
trying to mitigate this so one approach
was to try to automatically learn the
inner learning rate of the of the
algorithm basically learned that alpha
parameter that was in those equations
and specifically one of the things that
these papers have found to work to be
particularly important here is to learn
I did learn a rate that course that is
different for each parameter or
different for each for each layer of the
network and this is because things like
biases and weights may want to have
different learning rates bias these may
want to have larger learning rates
weights may want to have smaller
learning rates and you want them do you
want to be able to decouple kind of
those those different choices for those
different layers such that they don't
have the sort of conflicting
optimization and then there's also an
approach that tried to tune the outer
learning rate as well there are
approaches that try to authorize only a
subset of the parameters in the inner
loop such as like some of the parameters
that are out like affine transformations
on each of the layers there are papers
that have looked at decoupling the inner
learning rate kind of as I mentioned
before as well as the about storm
statistics per gradient stuff so you
have a different learning rate for each
gradient step for a different learning
rate or a different set of batch storm
statistics for each gradient step as
well and then lastly there are also some
papers that have introduced context
variables for increased expressive power
that basically introduced variables that
additional variables into the neural
network that are appended on to the
activations at each layer and allow the
gradient steps to store information and
those parameters in a way that doesn't
interfere with the other parts of the
network computation so for me the kind
of the main takeaway from these papers
that I think would be helpful for you is
that there's a range of simple tricks
that can help the meta optimization
process significantly are there any
questions on these challenges before I
move on to the next set
okay so one more challenge I'd like to
go into a bit more depth on is that back
propagating through many inter gradient
steps is gonna be very compute intensive
and very memory intensive so if you if
you have one greater gradient step or a
few inner gradient steps it's generally
quite practical to think about how you
might back propagate through only a
couple of those but if you have an
extended optimisation process in the
inner loop that is very challenging to
think about how you'd actually back
propagate through that in a way that
doesn't require storing the entire
optimization process in memory and
doesn't require back propagating ideally
doesn't require back propagating across
through that entire that optimization
process so there are two approaches that
have been kind of proposed for dealing
with this the first is a very crude
approach for dealing with it which is
just to approximate the Jacobian of the
task-specific parameters Phi I with
respect to the meta parameters theta as
the identity this is a very crude
approximation it basically corresponds
to a kind of truncated back propagation
in some regard where you just take the
gradient at those lost parameters and
copy it over to theta somewhat
surprisingly this actually works pretty
well on a number of simple few shot
learning problems like many imagenet
like Omniglot that we've discussed in
this class but anecdotally from what I
found it doesn't work in more complex
metal learning problems such as in meta
imitation learning problems but it's
something that's that's probably worth
trying if you have a setting where you
are compute bound or memory bound it's
also I think aesthetically not as
pleasing cuz it's a bit of a hack in
some regards like we know that this this
matrix is not actually close to identity
and then so I guess one way to think
about this is can we try to compute the
meta gradient without differentiating
through this optimization process and in
a way that doesn't approximate this
optimization process as ID and this is
where I want to go to the whiteboard to
kind of discuss how we might tried to do
this so as you remember I guess from
last
if you write down the the meta gradient
you get a form that looks like a single
backward pass at your at your task
specific parameters and then you have a
term that basically is differentiating
through the update rule so if you have
you basically need to be able to compute
D of U of theta with respect to your
parameters theta and this requires
storing all of the iterance of this
update rule if you try to do it kind of
with standard back propagation
approaches and so what we'd like to be
able to do is compute this derivative
without differentiating through this
entire optimization path that got you
there so the first thing that's worth
noting is we're gonna have to compute
this update this forward process of the
update rule no matter what so we're
still gonna at least have one full
forward pass through that update rule
but there are things that we can do to
try to mitigate the meta gradient
optimization so to write first let's
kind of write down what this update rule
looks like and in particular we're going
to use the update rule that corresponds
that has an explicit Gaussian prior on
the on the parameters and we'll see why
this matters in a second so let's say
that Phi is equal to the output of our
update procedure this update procedure
takes as input a set of training data
points and let's say that this is equal
to the solution to some optimization
problem on the parameters with respect
to our training data set and then also
with respect to explicit Gaussian
regularization that tries to keep our
toss parameter as close to the
parameters theta so this is just a
captured regularization with me and
theta and variance that's a function of
lambda note here in this case we're
gonna be looking at an inner
optimization that is actually two
conversions
that's trying to actually take the full
argument rather than just running one or
a few steps of gradient descent and if
we're going to be doing that that
actually having this regularization term
is really important because if we
ignored this term and just initialize it
at theta then it actually found the
minimum of this function that minimum
wouldn't actually be a function of theta
is not a function of theta then we don't
actually we aren't actually imposing any
prior on that inner optimization process
and so this is what that's what the role
of this what this regularization is
doing it's basically imposing this prior
on the inner optimization okay so let's
refer to this function right here as G
of Phi Prime and theta v prime is Phi
prime is just our optimization variable
and if we actually find the argument of
this of this function then we know that
the gradient of G with respect to Phi
prime is equal to 0 because we found
kind of the local optimum right and so
what we can write is that we can write
down that if this is equal to 0 then we
know that the gradient with respect to
and sorry actually this is evaluated at
Phi prime equals Phi so if you know this
that we know that the gradient of the
first loss term I'm gonna start dropping
the d-train for for notational
convenience we know that the gradient of
the first term plus the gradient of the
second term which is just lambda times
Phi minus theta is equal to zero so this
is just plugging in the gradient of G
and then from there we can rearrange
terms a bit so so let's bring Phi on the
left hand side of the equation and then
we can write out that this is equal to
theta
- 1 over lambda times the gradient of
Phi lsi so here we're just rearranging
terms from this bottom equation we're
from this distillation right here and
then if we differentiate this with
respect to theta because we're trying to
ultimately get D Phi D theta up there we
get the D Phi D theta is equal to di
daddy
which is just the derivative of that - 1
over lambda times the derivative of the
outside which is the Hessian at Phi
times the chain rule D Phi D theta ok
and so interestingly what we can do here
is we can arrange the terms a little bit
and try to solve for D Phi D theta and
the result of that is going to be
something that actually doesn't depend
on the optimization path and only
depends on the final point of that
optimization so in particular what we
can do is we could arrange try to put
well let's put a on on it and one side
on so and we get if you move this over
to the left we get the identity - 1 over
lambda
Ella Phi all of this times D Phi D theta
equals identity so this was just moving
this term over to the right and then
what we get is that we get D Phi D theta
equals basically the inverse of this
term
all right so one of the nice things
about this is well this is exactly what
we wanted to get and this only depends
on the passion at the final optimization
point and so that means that this is
actually something that we can compute
without actually differentiating through
that in our optimization process which
is quite nice and I guess the the
assumptions that we made to get there is
that the that basically that this inner
solve is accurate that it gets to a
point where the gradient is zero and
that we of course can compute this and
there are ways that we can try to
estimate this by using conjugate the
conjugate gradient algorithm which tries
to estimate basically this hat these
Hessian vector products of course this
is just this is just something that
looks like a Hessian and then the actual
gradient that will be for performing is
the gradient that we derived from last
time that corresponds to the the back
propagated vector at that optimization
point times this term right here yeah
yeah so there are kind of as I was
mentioning you can use conjugate
gradient algorithms to try to estimate
this inverted matrix term and basically
the number of iterations that you run of
conjugate gradient the more accurate
your estimate of this term will be and
at convergence it will be or if you run
kind of it for for infinite number of
iterations you'll get an exact estimate
or you'll get you'll approach an exact
estimate of this if you do zero
iterations of conjugate gradient you
actually just estimate this as the
identity which is actually just exactly
the which is exactly the kind of first
order mammal algorithm that's written up
there okay so what does this give us so
this used what's called the implicit
function theorem which is a way to kind
of think about how to differentiate
functions implicitly to get these to get
kind of this
of the gradient and so you can look at
the sagar than one of the nice things
that you get is that particularly it's
very memory efficient so you don't have
to store that optimization process and
then computationally as you increase the
number of conjugate gradients EPs you'll
it'll become more compute intensive and
that it allows you to basically
trade-off how accurate you want the meta
gradient to be with how much compute you
want to spend and so in particular what
these plots are showing the first is
showing the GPU memory on a very simple
very simple mental learning algorithm
and as we see the kind of change the
number of inner gradient steps both
first order mammals shown in purple and
implicit mammal as this algorithm is
called shown in green are constant in
memory as you increase the number of
gradient steps because they don't
actually do anything to store those to
store the documentation procedure
whereas the full mammal great mammal
algorithm increases linearly in memory
as you have to increase the number of
integrated steps yeah yeah so in
practice you would want more integrated
steps or I guess in theory you would
want more inner gradient steps in order
to try to have this this be more
accurate and practice we found that the
algorithm doesn't need well you'd still
run the algorithm in practice with with
without that condition being true and
getting gradients that are reasonably
accurate and then the second part is
showing computation time and so you can
see that for different numbers of
conjugate gradient steps shown in green
gray and red we see an increase in the
amount of computation and then with
mammal because you're computing you're
basically computing the the full
gradient you don't have an effective way
to trade off how much computation you
want as a function of the accuracy of
the meta gradient
okay so and then I guess the other
benefit of this approach is that it
means that you can use second-order
optimizers in the inner loop you can use
really I you can also include basically
non-differentiable optimizers in the
inner loop because this really just
depends on the the final term and not
actually the optimization process itself
being differentiable and so for example
we used a hessian-free optimization
approach in combination with us
algorithm and we're able to outperform
methods that use just like gradient
descent based in our optimizers okay
and then the last thing worth mentioning
about this algorithm that is that it's a
very recent develop and and so that all
the typical caveats with recent work
apply and that no a lot of people have
tried to kind of play around with this
approach and fully test it's it's um its
capabilities and its limitations okay
any questions on this before moving on
okay so the I guess the takeaway for
optimization based methods is that I you
do them by constructing in a bi-level
optimization procedure where the inner
optimization is something like gradient
descent like SVM's like hessian-free
optimization procedures and then
differentiate or either differentiate
through that optimization procedure or
do something like we did here in order
to compute the meta gradients the
benefits of this type of approach is
that you get a positive inductive bias
at the start of meta learning because
you're already have this optimization
procedure in the loop and you get
already expected to do something
reasonable at initialization time in
contrast to blackbox approaches where
the initial optimization procedure is
just some neural network another
takeaway or a kind of positive note
about these are these procedures is that
they're consistent and that they the
procedure that you run at test time
corresponds to an actual optimization
method and as a result you can tends to
extrapolate better to learning problems
that are outside of the distribution of
what you've seen during meditating and
we'll get back to this point a little
bit more at the very end of the lecture
and there also max
only expressive if you have a very deep
neural network oh and the last thing is
its model agnostic so it's pretty easy
to combine with different model
architectures now in terms of
limitations this requires typically a
second order optimization either by
differentiating through that that
optimization or by doing something like
this where you still have second order
terms that pop up and as a result it's
usually pretty compute or memory
intensive okay so now that we've talked
about kind of embedding gradient-based
authorization procedures into the inner
loop one question you might ask is can
we embed some other learning procedures
into the meta learning process without
requiring a second order optimization
and this is kind of where nonparametric
methods are going to fit in it so in
particular what we've been thinking
about is how we can learn parametric
models and there's this whole other
class of machine learning methods
nonparametric methods namely that are
simple and worked very well in low data
regimes these are things like nearest
neighbors for example if you have a
small amount of data these methods are
actually quite effective at learning and
during bed attest time if you taught
learning is exactly precisely in the
load data regime and so these
nonparametric methods are likely to
perform pretty well but of course during
méditerranée we still want to be
parametric because we want to be able to
scale to large data sets and so they
kind of key idea of these types of
approaches is could we use parametric
model learners to produce effective
nonparametric learners great so and I
guess one of the kind of side note here
is a lot of these nonparametric methods
proceeded some of the parametric
approaches that I've been talking about
but for the sake of this kind of this
lecture we'll be presenting them
afterwards okay so the key idea here is
to use some sort of nonparametric
learner and one kind of nonparametric
learner is to think about doing nearest
neighbors so if you want to be able to
perform this huge out learning problem
one very natural
proulx that actually mean someone may
have mentioned this earlier in the
course is to think about well why don't
we just like take this test data point
and compare it to all the training data
data points and look at each of these
train data points and find the one that
looks the most similar and then return
the one returns label corresponding to
the one that looks the most similar
basically compare the test image with
your training images know the kind of
the key question comes up is how do you
compare them with what metric do you
compare your test image to your training
image and if you weren't using something
like medal learning what you might do
with these types of methods is use
something like L to distance between
your data points unfortunately with
images L to distance is works very
poorly so one really nice example of
this is if you take this query image on
the right and compare it with the two
images on the left l/2 distance is going
to return the image on the left and this
does doesn't very good doesn't
correspond well with I kind of
perceptual distances and more semantic
distances between images and so the key
idea of these methods is instead of
comparing in the space of your
observations can you learn how to
compare using your meditating data in a
way that is effective for new tasks ok
so I guess the kind of the first type of
approach that we might imagine doing
here I was proposed by Coke in 2015 and
what they do is they train a Siamese
Network to predict whether or not two
images are of the same class so you're
essentially learning to compare pairs of
images and saying whether or not they're
the same class or not and so what this
could do is it could learn a more
semantic distance between two images and
so you can take these two images we know
that in our Mediterranean dataset these
are of different classes so the label
for this side of these neural network
would be 0 for this pair of images these
are 2 2 images that are from the same
semantic class and so though this would
correspond to 1 and you repeat this for
different pairs of images in your
meditating data set asking the neural
network to predict whether or not
they're from the same class or not
so at meditating time we're doing these
pairwise comparisons and then if we want
to be able to do few shot classification
that met a test time what we do is we
compare each image X test to each of
your images in your training data set
for that task basically just like we
mentioned a few slides ago and then you
output the label corresponding to the
closest image so if your classifier for
example outputs a probability of 0.9 for
the third image and a a probability of
zero point two for the second image and
something lower than 0.9 for all the
others and you would output the one that
has the highest highest likelihood
prediction corresponding to your course
find to the label of that of that image
so that the output the label that has
the that course was the image with the
highest likelihood of matching your test
image all right so this is pretty nice
it's also really simple and what we're
doing is I'd met during my the training
time we're training this binary
classifier and then it met a test time
we're performing an N way classification
by doing each of these pairwise
comparisons now one thing you might ask
is well okay we talked a lot about
Mediterranean about a testing and trying
to match what happens at Mediterranean
meta testing and here we're not Matt
like these are these are different
procedures right we're not actually
training it to do anyway classification
we're training it to do something else
we're trying to do binary classification
so is there a way that we can try to
match what happens during méditerranée
and what happens during med a testing so
it's that we're training it to be able
to be good at anyway classification
rather than training it to be good at
binary classification so this was kind
of the key idea introduced in the
matching networks paper and in
particular if we're going to be doing
nearest neighbors test time in order to
match our test query image to each of
our training data points how about we
train an embedding space such that
nearest neighbors produces accurate
predictions so here's an example of what
this looks like so we
each of the images in our training
dataset we embed them into a learned
embedding space we then take our test
query image and also embed that into an
embedding space and we compare each of
each of these embeddings to make a
prediction so each of these black dots
here will correspond to a comparison
between the the test embedding and the
training embeddings and then we'll take
the label correspond to each of our
training images and our prediction will
correspond to the weighted nearest
neighbors basically the weighted labels
of each of the training images or the
training labels weighted by their
similarity score all right and then I
guess once you do this you can then
train your neural network end-to-end in
order to make effective predictions on
your test data points so the particular
architecture they use in this paper was
they use a convolutional encoder to kind
of embed the images and they also use
this bi-directional STM to produce the
embeddings of each of the training data
points although in practice you could
choose up this you could choose simpler
things for these for each of these
models and as I mentioned the model is
trained end to end and most critically
your meta training is matching what's
happening at meta testing so during
about a training you're training it to
make comparisons to all the images in
your training dataset and at maddest s
time you're doing the same thing making
predictions for each of the four the
anyway classification problem that
you're going to be doing yeah so in this
case I think that their motivation here
was such that the basically information
about two different classes can be
spread to up to one another basically
like if you're trying to be classifying
between four different types of dogs for
example versus between a dog and a cat
the way that you represent your
embedding might be different for example
if you're trying to classify between
dogs and cats you're embedding space
you're embedding of a dog should
represent something that is something
is kind of general to all types of dogs
whereas if you're trying to do a more
fine-grained classification of
classified between two types of dogs
then you want that embedding space to be
more discriminative based on the type of
dog yeah right so with because of the
Ellis TM it does actually impose an
order for this for this particular
architecture in practice the there and
there are other bases there are other
nonparametric methods that aren't order
dependent and the next method that we'll
talk about is not order dependent I need
it for this particular paper they chose
the order arbitrarily okay so how do we
go about actually trading this so the
general algorithm looks basically the
same as the algorithms that we're taking
they were looking at before so if we
take the algorithm correspond to the
amortized or correspond to the black box
approach if we want to think about how
we do this for matching networks we
first sample about two tasks we sample a
train data set and a test data set for
each of those tasks we then compute
predictions using this learned
similarity metric and know here that
unlike the parametric methods we don't
have these parameters Phi they're
essentially integrated out into this
comparison and hence it's a
nonparametric approach and then once you
have these frictions then we update our
the parameters of this learning
embedding function with respect to the
loss function of how accurate our
predictions are on the test set although
note here that I'm abusing notation a
bit and that the kind of this loss
function would be something like
cross-entropy for example and would use
the predicted distribution over test
labels rather than only the only the
output that the max label okay so any
questions on how you would go about
training matching networks
okay so now one thing that we might
think about is well if we're doing
one-shot classification where we have
one example part class this is pretty
straightforward because we're gonna be
making basically we're gonna be making
big comparisons to each of those classes
but what if we're in the case where we
have more than one shot if we have more
than one data point per class
then what matching networks is gonna do
is gonna be performing these comparisons
independently and so if we have if we're
doing dog versus cats for example and we
have two dogs and two cats it's just
gonna find the closest image and output
the label corresponding to that or
basically do a weighted average of those
and look at the two dogs independently
and look at the two cats independently
in our training data set and so one
thing we might think about is well maybe
it makes sense to think about a more
aggregated like to aggregate information
per class in a way that is smarter than
just performing these independent
comparisons and that's what prototypical
networks do is so they think about how
can we aggregate class information to
create a prototypical embedding of that
class and then perform comparisons to
each of those prototypical prototypical
class embeddings in order to predict the
label corresponding to our test image
okay so with this more concretely looks
like is we'll have a number of images
for different classes so here different
colors correspond to different image
classes in our training data set for a
particular task and then we embed those
each of our training images into this
embedding space and then take the
average in this embedding space in order
to compute the prototypical embedding
for class 1 class 2 and class 3 and then
we embed our test image into this same
exam exact space and compute the
distance to each of those prototypical
class embeddings and then we can output
the one output the class for which it is
closest to in this embedding space so
what this looks like in equations is
will embed our each of our images in for
a particular class
into this embedding space and then take
the average for each of for each of
those images to compete this
prototypical embedding CK for class K
and then to compute which class to
compete the class of our test data point
we will take the distance between the
embedded test data point in each of
those classes and perform a softmax over
each of those each of those negative
distances in order to compute the
probability for the test data plan and
then in this case D can correspond to
Euclidean distance or cosine distance
some kind of your favorite different
distance metric in this but computed in
this learned embedding space all right
so this is an algorithm that you'll be
implementing in homework 2 are there any
questions on how it works
okay cool so this is per typical
networks basically when it corresponds
to is basically what but maybe the
purchased correspond to is basically
embed your data points and then do
nearest neighbors in that learned
embedding space now one challenge that
might come up is well what if you want
to do reason about more complex
relationships between data points rather
than just doing nearest neighbors in
your embedding space in principle if you
have it expressive enough encoder in
your embedding space the nearest
neighbors should be able to represent a
wide range of complex relationships
pretty clearly for high dimensional
embedding spaces but in practice people
have found it to be useful to think
about more expressive ways to perform
these types of comparisons so for
example relation networks basically
takes prototypical networks and learns a
nonlinear relation module on top of
those embeddings this basically just
corresponds to learning that function D
in prototypical networks instead of
using a Euclidean distance metric or a
cosine distance metric so learning both
the embedding and the distance metric
another approach is to instead of having
a single prototype per per class have a
mixture of prototypes per class and this
allows you to for example represent more
multi modal class distributions so maybe
one class maybe if you have kind of the
class dog maybe dogs are often either
seen on snow or on grass and you want to
be able to represent both of those both
of those kind of modes of your class in
your embedding space it may be easier to
try to allow your embedding space to
have a multi modal distribution rather
than trying to kind of change your
embedding space in a way that puts them
all on the same part of the embedding
space and then lastly another paper is
looked at can we embed at perform an
embedding on all of our data points and
then do some sort of message passing
scheme in order to think about how these
different data points relate to each
other
and in order to make their predicted
output and what this does is it uses
graph neural networks in order to
perform this message passing and
differentiate through it
okay um so no that's kind of mostly it
for nonparametric methods there they're
quite simple and we'll talk a bit about
some of the takeaways of these methods
in kind of the last part of this lecture
where we talked about how we can think
about comparing these approaches okay
and so I guess as a more meta point we
have all these algorithms are really
these kind of three classes of
approaches that we've talked about block
box adaptation optimization based
approaches and nonparametric approaches
and so how should you think about how
these different methods compare I think
that there are a few different ways to
think about this and so I'll present two
different ways to think about this and
the first is to think about the kind of
computation graph perspective how do
these different algorithms look like as
different computation graphs and we
visited we kind of talked about this
viewpoint earlier where the black box
approaches are representing this
computation graph in a completely black
box approach whereas optimization based
approaches you can view them as
embedding an optimization into your
computation graph and for nonparametric
approaches you can also take this view
and in particular what the computation
graph will look like for prototypical
networks for example is something that
for your test data point embeds it and
compares it to each of your per class
prototypes where those protoss
prototypes are computed using the
embedding of each of those each of those
classes data plans so you can centrally
just view it as another kind of
computation graph or we're embedding the
soft nearest neighbors into the
computation graph okay so with this view
we can also think about how we can mix
and match components of the computation
graph to get hybrid types of approaches
yeah
yeah so you can essentially view all of
these methods as a computation graph and
whether or not that company liked the
optimization based methods and
nonparametric methods are essentially
imposing a certain type of structure
inside your computation graph that
corresponds to things like gradient
descent and nearest neighbors
whereas blackbox methods tend to not
impose any structure on that process
there is a bit of a gray line between
like why what computation graphs look
more like nonparametric methods versus
what computation graphs look more like
blackbox methods I think it's helpful to
think about this this kind of different
classification of methods because it
allows us to think about the certain
properties of these these methods
although in practice there isn't a very
clear cut line between them yeah yeah
that's a good point so it should be over
X Y such that y equals K yeah exactly
and I'll try to fix that I noticed that
on the previous slide and I'll try to
fix that on the before you post those
slides online okay is there a question
in the back ok so we can again because
we get to give you this computation
graphs is also is pretty easy to think
about how we might try to mix and match
component cities so one approach which
is a bit of a hybrid of blackbox
approaches and optimization based
approaches or maybe optimization based
nonparametric depending on the way you
view things is it approach that tries to
condition a model on an embedding of the
data set of your train data set and also
run gradient descent on that model and
practice this sort of these sources of
information by conditioning on the data
with the direct weight as well as
through gradient descent could
potentially be redundant although in
practice it seems like this method found
some benefit and doing that another idea
here that you could do is have some sort
of embedding
of your function and then do gradient
descent on that embedding space and so
pretty clear they have this paper uses a
relation network to embed your training
dataset and think about how different
data points relate to one another and
then they decode this embedding into the
parameters of a neural network that
makes predictions about new data points
and then instead of running gradient to
set all the parameters of that function
they run gradient descent in the learned
embedding space Z which produces
different functions so you'd essentially
view it as running gradient descent on a
lower dimensional space of your weights
rather than running gradient descent in
the original space of your weights okay
and then the last approach that I'll
cover is that there's also depression
that looked at doing something exactly
like mammal but initializing the last
layer of the network to correspond to
prototypical networks so it's a pretty
basically specific form of as this
particular choice of the network
architecture for mammal that initializes
it to do something like a comparison
based a comparison based prediction okay
so that's the kind of computation graph
view is one way to think about how these
different algorithms compare and the
other way that I like to think about how
these algorithms compare is to think
about the different properties of the
individual algorithms and in particular
I think there are two properties that
are really important as we start to
think about developing meta learning
algorithms and developing new meta
learning algorithms the first is
thinking about expressive power of these
algorithms so we talked about this a bit
before is basically the ability for that
function f then I showed on the previous
slide to represent a range of learning
procedures as a function of as a
function of your training data set and
the reason why this is important is that
it means that as you get more larger and
larger
mediterrean data sets you'll be able to
produce a more flexible range of learned
optimizers and as you apply these types
of algorithms to more challenging
optimization problems you'll be able to
do better than the
the standard optimization procedures we
have today so it simply has to do with
scalability and where these methods will
end up in the future if you could only
represent a small class of algorithms
then your you may not be as effective
when moving towards broader
Mediterranean data sets ok so this is
the first property and the second
property which I alluded to very briefly
before is the property of consistency
and in particular what I mean by
consistency is that the Miller algorithm
will produce a learned learning
procedure that will solve the task with
enough data regardless of the properties
of that task it'll essentially produce a
consistent learning procedure such that
given enough data I guess what I mean by
consistent learning procedure is one
that will kind of asymptotically solve
the task given enough data at that task
and so for example things like gradient
descent correspond to a consistent
learning procedure because they're just
running great to send a test time and
you expect at the end of given enough
data for that test task you'll be able
to solve a task regardless of what your
meta training data was now what is why
is this important well first getting
meta training data that corresponds I'll
get to your question our second first
getting meditating data that corresponds
closely to what you'll be seeing at test
time is pretty hard so we haven't really
talked about this much but we've been
assuming that we have this meta trained
at ASET and we can use this
Mediterranean data set in a set of tasks
in order to do well at new tasks but in
practice how do we determine what those
tasks actually correspond to this is
actually a really hard problem as we
think about where we're going to be
applying these algorithms and so if we
produce a consistent learning procedure
that we can expect it to do something
reasonable on tasks that aren't
necessarily especially close to the bed
of training tasks that we train it on
and we can also get basically get better
out of distribution tasks performance
there's a question
yeah so I guess the question was about
like can't we have a catastrophic
initialization that's that green doesn't
actually give us a good solution and I
guess the short answer is yes I guess
one thing we can assume with gradient
descent is it will at least get to a
local optimum whether that local optimum
is good or not is it kind of another
question and it could be that or and we
could have an initialization that puts
us in a place that the local optimum is
actually very bad for that particular
Basin the so absolutely that's and
that's something I think that people
haven't thought about quiet as much yet
and so thinking about how we might how
we might try to tackle that sort of
problem and does it actually happen in
practice does we do we actually get to
local often that are bad it's kind of
another question
[Music]
something like that yeah yeah so there
are other ways to try to think about how
you might formalize this problem as well
it's something like basically montauk
improvement it could be one of them as
well yeah and I guess theoretically
thinking about that sort of problem may
also draw very closely to some of the
theoretical questions and deep learning
in general like our local optimum good
with high probability things like that
and people have started have looked at
that sort of problem in the past okay
and I guess one thing I was going to
mention here is that we recall that this
in practice things like gradient descent
if we're running at test time do tend to
empirically actually hold up with regard
to getting better out of distribution
test performance in comparison to
blackbox adaptation approaches okay and
so in my mind these are the kind of the
two properties that are most important
for many different applications of meta
learning not necessarily the benchmarks
that we have because the benchmarks are
well defining a nice set of meta
training tasks instead of meta test
tasks that kind of closely align with
that but in practice if we're thinking
about applying these algorithms on real
problems these are the two properties
that I think that we're gonna care about
the most
okay and so let's think about how these
how the different algorithms compare on
these different axes so for blackbox
approaches we know that they have
complete expressive power in the respect
that
things like recurrent neural networks
are universal function approximator z'
and we also know that they're not
consistent the in that they won't if you
are imposing any structure on the
function on your black box function then
they will there's no guarantees that
they'll produce anything that is
consistent okay for authorization based
methods we know that it reduces to
gradient descent at least for things
like mammal and so in that sense they're
consistent for some definition of
consistent with regard to things like
monotonic improvement and we also know
that they are expressive if you have
deep enough models and in practice we
found these methods to perform well on
on on settings where you do want to be
fairly expressive with regard to few
shop learning algorithms I put in
Asterix here because this actually
doesn't hold up in some reinforcement
learning settings and will potentially
talk about this a bit later in the
course it mostly holds in supervised
learning settings it also depends on the
particular reinforcement learning
algorithm that you use so it's a bit of
a nuanced a nuanced thing that we'll
discuss later and then with regard to
nonparametric approaches these methods
are expressive for most architecture
choices for example if you're using
things like owl stems then there are a
wide range of functions that you can't
represent although there's a bit of
nuance depending on the types of
learning algorithms that you might want
to learn and they're also consistent
under certain conditions so they are
consistent in the sense that if you're
embedding is not losing information that
is losing information about the inputs
that is not that that's important for
making decisions then as you accumulate
more and more data you'll eventually get
something I'd kind of awesome totally
you'll eventually get to a data point
that's arbitrarily close to your test
data point and then be able to make the
correct prediction for that test data
point okay
so beyond these all we got on these
properties there's also other properties
that are pretty important for thinking
about with regard to different
applications so things like being really
easy to combine too with a variety of
learning problems this is true for black
box approaches because it's really easy
to basically just plug in your plug in
different loss functions or different
optimization procedures into these types
of architectures the downsides as I
mentioned last time is that it does
involve a challenging optimization and
that there's no one good inductive bias
at initialization to point it in the
direction of a realization procedure in
as a result they're often fairly data
inefficient because you have to learn
how to learn completely from scratch
okay with the word optimization based
method as we talked about earlier we
have this positive inductive bias at the
start of metal learning because we're
initializing it with every
optimization algorithm it can handle I
guess one thing I didn't mention before
is it could handle varying K and large K
relatively well if you have more data
than what you trained on for example
these approaches still tend to work well
because they're consistent and they're
also model agnostic in the sense that
you can't plug in different
architectures and apply them with with
conceptually without any difficulty the
downsides as I mentioned before we have
a second order optimization and it's
usually compute intensive and memory
intensive and these two of these new
points are quite important for a range
of applications where you care a lot
about compute and memory particularly
when you're scaling to large data sets
okay and then with the road and
nonparametric methods we didn't cover
the pros and cons of this one yet other
than these two so the first is that one
of the nice things about these methods
is that they're entirely feed-forward
architectures they don't involve any any
back propagation within that computation
graph and so as a result they tend to be
very computationally fast and they tend
to be very easy to optimize in contrast
to architectures that involve recurrence
that involve gradients pushing backwards
etc and then some of the downsides of
these approaches is that they're hard to
generalize to varying K this is more of
an empirical observation that people
have found is if you test them on more
cane than what they're trained on they
tend to underperform with what other
algorithms are able to achieve it's also
harder to scale these two very large
data sets at test time because they're
using nonparametric approaches and so
far these methods have also been limited
to classification in principle you could
also apply them to things like
regression but the with the caveat that
you could only interpolate between the
labels if you kind of if you naively
apply these approaches to regression you
can only interpolate between the labels
that you saw in your in your task
specific training set because they're
just doing a weighted average of those
labels at test time okay
and then at a more high level it's worth
mentioning that generally well two
versions of each of these algorithms
tend to perform comparatively on
existing few shot benchmarks and as I
alluded to before things various bells
and whistles like using ensembles
they're using or tuning the architecture
can lead to are often they kind of the
differentiating factor between these
methods rather than the actual
underlying method itself
this likely says more about the
benchmarks than about the approaches
themselves and I think that basically in
many cases which method you want to use
will depend heavily on your use case and
whether or not you care about things
like consistency whether or not you care
about expressive power whether don't you
care about computational efficiency etc
okay any more questions on these kind of
how these algorithms compare and when
you might use one versus the other okay
so I guess that's mostly it the for
today so to recap we talked about to
algorithmic properties we also talked
about a computation graph perspective
one third property that's useful to
think about is thinking about
uncertainty awareness by this like me
and kind of the ability to reason about
ambiguity during the learning process at
test time and the reason why this is
important is that if you want to do
things like active learning or have
calibrated uncertainty estimates when
you're learning from small amounts of
data or if you're in reinforcement
learning settings and you want a reason
about what data you should collect in
order to reduce your uncertainty about
the task then you need to have some
notion of your uncertainty and
uncertainty comes up especially in
future learning problems where you only
have a small amount of data and your
prior can't necessarily make up for what
the true task is and the kind of the
other kind of place where this comes in
is that we talked about this really nice
Bayesian motivation at the beginning of
the course in the in the second lecture
and the third second to third lecture
and we've kind of moved to be moved to
fully deterministic approaches and in
the next lecture we'll talk
basically more principled Bayesian
approaches that get back to that initial
motivation and also give us things like
calibrate uncertainty or more calibrated
uncertainty and approaches that allow us
to think about how we could collect more
data to reduce our uncertainty and we'll
discuss all of those things on Monday on
Wednesday we have student presentations
again that will be covering various
various algorithms and extensions of the
things that we've been talking about and
then a few more reminders again homework
one is due on Wednesday please fill out
the poster presentation preferences for
the dates we need to know kind of when
you're available and the information
about the course project is online I'll
see you on Wednesday